let's talk today about the real
practical important differences between
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren now
I've been planning to do this for a
while but for whatever reason over the
weekend I started I saw on Monday
morning I had a bunch of tweets saying
David you are repeating the idea that
Bernie and Warren are the same now I
have no idea where this came from I've
been super clear that Bernie and Warren
are two different candidates from the
beginning whose policy positions are
different whose political ideology is
different I've been talking about it for
more than a year since whenever this
topic first came up so someone seems to
be confused but I have said that Bernie
and Warren are the two most progressive
candidates when it comes to the overall
package of ideas in the context of 20:19
politics and how we sort of evaluate the
progressiveness of ideas so let's get
right into it the biggest difference
between Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren is the origin of their political
ideology and their general philosophical
positioning now I'm not going to focus
as much on micro policy in this segment
I will mention some specific policies
but a lot of those micro policies number
one can change and number two rarely do
campaign promises become administration
accomplishments in reality it's not how
politics works of course we look at what
a candidate says they want to do it
matters but what really is at issue for
me here with the Bernie versus Warren
thing is the source and underpinnings of
their political ideologies it sounds
theoretical but yet it's practical
because the most stark difference today
between Bernie and Warren is in the
ideological area although I will get to
the policy differences Bernie and Warren
end up domestically very close on policy
although not the same and on foreign
policy there are more differences which
we'll talk about but Bernie Sanders has
ended up where he is today on the
political spectrum being pulled from his
1960s 1970s sort of hippie democratic
socialist origins Elizabeth Warren on
the other hand has been pulled to
the left over her lifetime from a much
more moderate leaning which included
actually being a registered Republican
for a lot of her life particularly more
moderate on economic policy on the one
hand bernie is more of a destroy the
system to build it back up mentality
where Elizabeth Warren is more of a fix
the problems we have and improve the
system that's already in place by
tweaking it and that is a massive
difference that difference is way bigger
than the difference on any micro policy
issues now on a lot of policies and
issues their immediate next step if they
were to be president is the same but not
always so let's talk about some more
specifics when it comes to reducing
inequality Elizabeth Warren has taken a
much more micro approach which doesn't
mean it's less ambitious but it is much
more micro which is let's put in a
wealth tax with the broader
infrastructure remaining as it is now in
terms of the number of dollars that
Elizabeth Warren's proposed wealth tax
would bring in towards reducing
inequality it is massive it is
significantly impactful but the approach
is very different Bernie Sanders has
talked about other ideas including
progressive taxation and a variety of
other programs but his approach is one
where he positions the current systems
as fundamentally wrong where Elizabeth
Warren doesn't so much consider the
system's wrong she feels the system is
incorrectly configured and to use like a
computer analogy she wants to change
some of the settings of the system
health care has been a topic of much
discussion and I admit it's not
completely transparent where Elizabeth
Warren exactly lands on the health care
issue but the way I'd characterize it is
Elizabeth Warren is not as in favor of
Medicare for all as the path forward as
is Bernie Sanders with Bernie we know
it's Medicare for all he has a plan for
Medicare for all he has a plan for how
to pay for Medicare for all and that is
his path Elizabeth Warren including in
the last debate has expressed support
for Medicare for all but it's very
that she is much more malleable in terms
of the range of solutions that she would
accept she said she supports different
ways of getting to universal health care
which is very different than what Bernie
Sanders says which is Medicare for all
is the way let's talk about foreign
policy a little bit and I I'm still of
the mindset that much like in 2016 one
of the primary criticisms that I could
make of Bernie Sanders bearing in mind
that he's one of my top candidates is
that he has at least not expressed deep
knowledge of a number of important
foreign policy issues now the critique
of Elizabeth Warren is not drastically
different when it comes to the depth of
knowledge that has been expressed now
that being said I have not heard much
from Bernie about for example what
should our relationship to China be I
know he's talked about it a little bit
around the edges but I've not seen in
detail what the the idea there should be
I've heard more from Elizabeth Warren on
that issue although her position is
relatively status quo on our
relationship with China with foreign
policy it again is a difference of
philosophical approach Bernie Sanders is
what has been sometimes called a
Democratic globalist when it comes to
applying a lot of the same
anti-authoritarian egalitarian
inequality reducing ideas to our
relationships with other countries
Elizabeth Warren exists in a much more
moderate space when it comes to foreign
policy taking a sort of standard
center-left approach on a lot of these
foreign policy questions now to be
perfectly honest I only find Elizabeth
Warren's policy ideas moderately
different from those of for example
Barack Obama in a lot of areas I think
domestically there's a big space there
between Warren and someone like Obama
but when it comes to foreign policy I
don't see Warren as nearly as much of a
progressive as we would potentially like
to see Bernie has been much more vocal
about his opposition to American support
for the Saudi war in Yemen then
Elizabeth Warren has
I'd want to hear from Elizabeth Warren
more about her position on that a major
difference Bernie voted against
increasing the Pentagon's budget
Elizabeth Warren voted for it that is a
fundamental difference in terms of the
view of how we should be managing this
issue of the the financial enabling of
American foreign policy and
interventionism bernie is much more
active in talking about American foreign
policy going back decades and how that
relates to the decisions we have to make
today then has a then Elizabeth Warren
has been Bernie talks about the history
of American foreign policy in a way
Warren does not and this is really
important because to make good decisions
today about American foreign policy in
order to avoid dropping us into the same
problems that American foreign policy
has caused in the past you have to
understand the history of American
interventionism and foreign policy
Bernie has much more often talked about
the destructive force of American
interventionism
around the world of military power over
the last 60 or 70 years by the United
States and the effect that is it has had
globally I've heard a lot less from
Elizabeth Warren on that now on domestic
policy I know that there are many
differences we could talk about
differences we could talk about Bernie
has said ban for-profit prisons and end
cash bail for example I looked and
wasn't able to find Elizabeth Warren
taking that position and she may not be
for those things and these are not
insignificant but relative to their
broader ideological differences I don't
know that that is where the focus should
be in talking about the difference
between these two so what's our
conclusion is Bernie more progressive on
a number of issues absolutely there's no
question about it they are not the same
would Elizabeth Warren still be the most
progressive president of the modern
political era if she were to be
President of the United States of course
she would while I would love to see a
Bernie presidency am I going to smear
Elizabeth Warren as a tool of the
establishment or is anything other than
someone who would also be the most
progressive
in the modern era no I'm not gonna do
that and I you know I will tell you that
her origin story is less progressive
than Bernie's she's more moderate on
some issues and both of these folks
would be the most progressive presidents
of the modern political era period now
what is not included here and it is a
different analysis is how likely each of
their respective policy positions are to
be made a reality if they were to be
President of the United States and
that's a topic for a different day tell
me what I'm missing tell me where I'm
going wrong tell me if I'm fundamentally
misunderstanding the differences between
these two candidates